en este pequeño rincón de allá donde se
habla español
[Aplausos]
ubicado en las afueras de la capital
camerunesa el barrio de teta que se
conecta con cataluña a través de la
asociación esportiva ramas a este
modesto club llegó en 2017 como parte de
una de sus giras solidarias anuales por
áfrica pero en este ataque la
institución se involucró en un proyecto
que da más allá de lo futbolístico con
la misión de ayudar a la comunidad a
gestionar las carencias diarias como
destaca uno de los jefes de la zona
el proyecto ramas aporta muchas cosas e
incluso ha alcanzado a la alcaldía es
gracias a esto que el alcalde viene a
menudo a animarnos a seguir el proyecto
roger somos de scouts bajo los colores
de ramas squash niños y niñas del barrio
acceden a clases de apoyo escolar y de
idiomas como español e inglés montagut
también cuentan con escuelas de danza
que van desde baile contemporáneo
a música y canto tradicional
clases de mecánica y de peluquería son
opciones para aquellos jóvenes que
abandonan los estudios
el corazón del proyecto en el terreno es
william viandas quien coordina las
actividades del club en este ataque
además de liderar la escuela de fútbol
que reúne a un centenar de niños y
también niñas aunque las clases
trascienden la pelota para nosotros no
se trata simplemente hablar de fútbol
pero el fútbol nos sirve como
herramienta que pone la gente junto y
luego podemos transmitir las valores
porque para nosotros lo más importante
son las valores humanas es por esperanza
esa es la palabra más repetida por los
alumnos en esta forma de tango
quería pan con más a mí
acceso al agua potable y luminarias en
las calles y mejoras en los ingresos al
barrio son algunas de las necesidades
por cubrir meta que por ahora cuentan
con ramas a el único apoyo tangible que
ha tenido este pueblo olvidado de yaundé